at first glance it seems simple to tell
one type of butterfly from the next
they're boldly colored wings appear to
differentiate one species from another
but predators must beware the wings of
butterflies tell lies
some butterflies have evolved wings that
resemble those of more poisonous species
a clever deception in other cases two
equally poisonous species have evolved
together to become mirror images of each
other the Amazonian butterfly he laconia
snoo mata has evolved in this way this
one species has many different wing
patterns copied from several different
species from the millennia genus this
kind of shared evolution is called
mullerian mimicry together Heliconius
and Melanie are spread an important
message to would-be predators don't eat
us we taste bad their similar appearance
makes them part of a cooperative that
protects them from being eaten while
Sciences new mullerian mimicry was at
work in these butterflies it was unclear
how he Laconia could derive so many
different wing patterns from only one
set of genes in the mid-1970s scientists
proposed that the wing mimicry of
Heliconius was under the control of
something called a super gene a long
stretch of DNA that contains many
smaller genes in the super gene
individual genes are immune to the
random mixing and matching that normally
occurs in sexual recombination this is
how Heliconius manages to keep its
various wing patterns separate although
the concept of a super gene fits with
what scientists observed in the field no
one has ever seen how it works until now
a study of Heliconius DNA led by french
scientist matias urine shows that the
super gene breaks and then recombines
into several different configurations
each arrangement creates a specific wing
pattern the mirror image of a melon air
species by mimicking it's poisonous
cousins Heliconius is safer from the
greedy gaze of predators so natural
selection favors these preset patterns
and by extension the genes that create
them
you
Oh